which is like question for you Joey
which is I have voice man curious like
how much studying have you done because
a lot of people assume that Joey's
Japanese is like a second language right
and it's completely wrong Joey has a
second first language like like a lot of
people would don't know this but Joey's
Japanese is better than most Japanese
people yeah
it's I had no idea how good your
Japanese was I just kind of thought that
you were like decent yeah yeah I'd like
but then I came here and then you were
teaching kanji to like 40 year old
people in the party and we had like
three people from our company Japanese
and I was like teaching them about like
different kanji structures in the [ __ ]
that were like I never heard of this
before and I'm like yeah um I did a lot
like write a lot a lot like when I say
I've said it in videos but like when
I've said like I've studied my entire
life like I'm not joking I've studied my
entire life um just to put it in
perspective when I was like like maybe
10 years old I know what I used to do
for fun whoa I used to read the kanji
dictionary I was that one kid I liked my
parents probably thought I was like
borderline autistic cuz like I would
like sit in my room as a ten-year-old
and I'm like I got nothing better to do
and I would just go to my mom's
bookshelf just take out this massive
like you know 2,000 pages yeah yeah just
open up to a random page and just read
it yeah well like hours on in and like I
don't know maybe I don't know how much
that actually helped me in the long run
but definitely it kind of got me like -
like familiarize myself with different
shapes and you know in that sense I'm
definitely a lot like Conaway yeah I'm
very good at learning things with the
only yeah I need visuals I had learning
sentences and stuff doesn't do anything
yeah no but like another huge thing for
me was probably the fact that like my
mom had like this like kind of this
unspoken rule where if I spoke to her in
English I would usually get ignored and
that's that's a really cruel especially
when like a four-year-old is really talk
to their mom about something and like
but I quickly picked up on it because
like
I was like four or five years old and
I'd like to bail a hey mom can I do you
know blah blah she just straight up
ignore me I'm like all right she's in a
pissed-off mood but then but then the
more times you experience and I'm like
oh I have to ask her in Japanese and the
moment I also in Japanese she's like yes
so that's a genius way to make you yeah
my mom my mom was exactly the same
answer I'm like thank I'm like now she's
like you can appreciate with this when
you're older but you are you you're
getting this now mom I appreciate that
now that I'm older I also appreciate
because like if if she didn't do that
then I wouldn't have just like I would
have forced myself to learn Thai or to
use Thai in a school setting which is
very hard when you're not living in the
country that you're using exactly you
know like everybody around me spoke
English right because I was living in
Australia and I had a few like childhood
friends who spoke Japanese but because
all my childhood friends were also hafiz
like me yeah sometimes we just spoke in
English to one another so like I needed
a wait I guess my mom was like all right
I need to find like a consistent way
with my son is keep speaking the
language just keep improving and like it
really helped as well because my mom was
like exceedingly good at Japanese and
when kanji and stuff like that
especially so like whenever I had like a
question or like I learned a new word I
always went to my mom and I try to force
myself to use that new word in a
sentence and she would be like she would
either say like oh that's not how you
use that word this is how you use it
dumb little she tell you how to use this
place she could immediately know when I
was trying to like where's like I you
just want that word didn't you because
she'd be like okay that's not quite how
you use it this is how you use it and
then I use it again and should be like
okay perfect and that's just how I
learnt from practicality